hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
right in front of me i have the ipad air
3 from last year and i have apple's
brand new
ipad air 4. and in this video we're
basically going to be looking at the
differences between the three and the
four to see
if you should upgrade if you have the
three and you're thinking about getting
the four
or in general just seeing how many
things got upgraded how many things
changed
so we're going to be taking a look at
the design differences we're going to
take a look at the displays the display
quality
the graphics performance everything like
that and the cameras as well
to see if it's basically worth upgrading
to the new ipad air 4. so what we're
going to start off with
is the design differences and the size
differences so right off the bat
the first thing i noticed right away
looking at the back is the cameras
you can see that the camera bump on the
air 4 is
massive i mean this is coming from the
camera from the ipad
pro a much larger sensor in camera and
we're actually going to be going into a
camera comparison
later on in this video apart from that
you can see that the microphone on the 4
is actually quite a bit larger than the
one on the
air 3 that's right over there so we are
going to be testing the microphone
quality as well now the absolute best
part of the air 4
is the new modern design with flat sides
and a flat back as you can see right
here
the air 3 had the classic chamfer design
so it rounded into the corners but the
air takes on the design from the
ipad pro so we have nice flat edges
flat sides just like the new iphone 12
lineup and
this honestly just feels so much more
premium and modern
now another difference is the size
because the ipad air the new one gets a
new
aspect ratio which we're going to talk
about in just a minute
it actually is a little bit wider
than the ipad air 3 and it's also not as
tall so the air 3 actually ends up being
a little bit taller
than the new ipad air one thing i really
love about the new flat design on the
ipad air 4 is that the buttons are much
easier to press because on the ipad r3
they're kind of
hidden behind those chamfered edges
so they're much harder to press compared
to the new ipad air
now one of the standout new features of
the air 4 is the new
touch id power button so you have touch
id built
into this power button which is a really
cool feature and we're actually going to
be comparing touch id between these two
in just
a moment but first i want to mention
that
the new air 4 does not get a headphone
jack
because i don't know apple just likes
getting rid of it and even though it
seems like the ipad air 4 is thinner
they're actually the exact same
6.1 millimeters thick so
yeah no headphone jack now finishing up
with a couple more differences
the air 4 has the smart connector on the
back and it's actually a little bit
larger than the
classic location of the smart connector
on the air 3
like we had before and one of the great
improvements is the usb
c ports on the ipad air 4. that is a
huge deal because the lightning port is
so limiting
in terms of connecting accessories and
supplying power to those accessories
so that's really nice now one of my
absolute favorite features of the air
for is that you get speaker grills
not only on the bottom like you get with
the air 3 but you also get them on the
top
so that gives you landscape stereo
speaker quality
which is going to help for everything
from watching movies netflix youtube
whatever or
gaming hearing footsteps around you so
that's definitely a nice plus
and we're gonna get into the speaker
comparison in just a couple of minutes
now finally moving on to the front here
is where we see
the biggest differences obviously the
ipad air 4 looks so much
modern with the new liquid retina
display
basically has rounded corners so it
looks more modern compared to this old
ancient design where you have the square
display
just like all the old iphones the ipad
air 4
looks like all of the new iphones like
the iphone 12 everything's nice and
rounded
and of course you no longer have that
home button
that the ipad air 3 has now this looks
really nice and clean
but the new air does not have face id
like the pro it has
touch id on the top compared to touch id
here so
comparing them honestly i kind of like
the old touch id because if it's laying
down like this
you can use your index finger very
easily open it up like that or if you're
holding the air 3
use your thumb and you can set different
fingerprints
in the settings compared to the air 4
you kind of have to reach up top
and it's a little bit annoying it's not
as convenient of a location
and like you kind of have to use your
index finger
it's kind of annoying now one of the
main advantages of having a power button
touch id
is that you can authenticate and unlock
your ipad at the same time
just like that but the air 3 had it as
well just with the home button
just like that but honestly the air 3
works better because you have more
surface area on that round touch id
sensor compared to the
slim power button which doesn't work as
often which really sucks now getting
into comparing the display quality
itself
the ipad air 4 has a 10.9 inch display
compared to 10.5 but the quality is
actually very very similar
but one benefit that i am noticing with
the new display is that
reflectivity isn't as big of an issue as
you guys can see
from that top down camera the new ipad
air 4
is less reflective and the display looks
a little bit more
black or a deeper black compared to the
air 3. so that's definitely nice
now comparing the maximum brightness
between these two
they're both rated at the same 500 nits
and looking from the top
they both look equally as bright but
i did turn off true tone on both of
these and the new ipad air looks to have
a much cooler display it looks more blue
compared to the ipad air 3 which is very
interesting
and when i look at it from different
angles
i honestly think that the old ipad air 3
has better viewing angles than the ipad
air 4 which is pretty
interesting so i guess that's one of the
downsides by going with the new
rounded corner display now comparing the
display quality they both support
p3 wide color gamut and they're both
using lcd panels so
they're not oled but what's really cool
is that in youtube
they both now support 4k 60 which is
really great looking from the top cam
they both look really good
but i am noticing that you're getting
more surface area on the new ipad air 4
and that's because
we're getting rid of the home button so
the display is actually a little bit
wider when you're in landscape mode so
you're getting a larger
image or picture from youtube and you're
getting
smaller black bars on the top and bottom
so that's really nice
but as far as the color of reproduction
and things like that i'm not really
noticing any differences here
now let's get into the speaker
comparison now before we begin i want to
remind you guys that the air
4 has speakers on the left and the right
when you're in landscape
but the air 3 only has them on the right
side so you guys won't be able to hear
that difference because we're using a
mono microphone but
keep that in mind and let's get started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
all right guys now i don't know about
you but the new air 4 while it did sound
louder because you have speakers on both
sides
definitely more immersive the speakers
themselves actually sounded a little bit
flat compared to the ipad air 3 which
had kind of
sharper highs and more dynamic range
like the speakers are
better it seems like compared to having
them on both sides on the air 4.
but even with that downside i still
prefer
the new air because it's so much more
immersive having it on both sides
and with that let's get into comparing
the apple pencil experience
the air 3 supports the original apple
pencil
it uses the really weird way of charging
where you
plug it into the bottom into the
lightning port
it's really annoying it really sucks
this is how you pair and charge
i really don't like it but the new air 4
has the second generation apple pencil
which uses the
wireless charger on the side it
magnetically snaps into place
it pairs like this it charges like this
so much better of an experience
compared to the original apple pencil
and comparing the pencils themselves
the new one has a matte feel and i
honestly like it so much
better it's a little bit smaller and it
just feels more
compact and better in your hand compared
to the old longer
glossy finish now the new one also has
a double tap gesture so you just tap
double tap like this
on the edge and you can do things like
switch between tools
zoom in zoom out in documents and stuff
like that so
definitely the better apple pencil it's
actually a hundred and thirty dollars
compared to a hundred that's the only
downside but i'd say that it's
definitely worth it now let's get into
comparing the cameras starting with the
selfie cams
they both actually use 7 megapixel
sensors so you could do
1080p video and just let me know which
one of these
selfies looks better to you and of
course on the rear the air 4 has a much
larger camera from the ipad pro it's
actually 12 megapixels compared to
8 on the ipad air 3. and that basically
gives it sharper photos and it allows it
to shoot
at 4k 60 whereas the ipad air 3 cannot
do that so that's definitely a nice
advantage
now getting into comparing the webcams
and the microphone
quality this is the audio quality on the
ipad air 3. and this is the microphone
quality on
the ipad air 4. let me know which one is
better down below and i'm actually
noticing that this one looks
way more cropped in which is really
weird but i did have a couple of options
to shoot in
1080p 60fps where i didn't have those
options on
the air 3 so that's kind of nice now
finally getting into the performance
comparison
the air 3 has the a12 bionic chip
compared to the a14 bionic on the air 4
so that's
two generations newer on top of that you
also get four gigabytes of ram with the
air
4 compared to 3 with the old air so
that's also a nice
jump up for multi-tasking and things
like that but let's go ahead and jump
into the
cpu comparison all right we have our
scores back
and wow this is just insane in terms of
the single core test we're getting 42
percent
faster performance compared to the air 3
which is incredible this is actually the
highest single core score we've seen on
any computer out there and in terms of
the multi-core
it's actually 50 percent more multi-core
performance
this is a massive jump going from
one generation from the air 3 to the air
4. it's incredible
and now of course let's get into that
graphics test
this difference right here i was not
expecting that is just
insanity we're getting well over
twice the graphics performance on the
new ipad air 4.
and this is actually the best score
we've had on
any iphone any ipad even the ipad pro
this beats the ipad pro and graphics
performance it's just
incredible so wow now the only downside
with
this level of performance is that the
a14 chip has been known
to get worse battery life because of the
crazy graphics performance
it ends up draining the battery so you
might actually get less battery life
than the ipad air 3 when you're playing
games and stuff like that
now the final thing i want to cover
before we get into our conclusion
on if it's worth upgrading to the ipad
air 4 is
keyboard case support because of the new
design
the ipad air 4 supports the magic
keyboard case
that we got on the ipad pro now i love
this i personally think it's the best
keyboard case ever because of this
unique
floating hinge design and we also have a
pass
usb-c charging port on the side which
you basically don't get
on any other keyboard case now for the
ipad air 3 you get more traditional
keyboard cases like the
logitech combo touch which supports the
10.2 inch ipad and
this ipad air 3. now what's nice about
this is that you have
a detachable keyboard and of course you
also have the
trackpad which is really nice as well
the benefit with this one is that it's a
lot cheaper it's a hundred and fifty
dollars compared to
three hundred dollars for the magic
keyboard but this
is the most premium keyboard case
because the keyboard the keys themselves
feel
much much better maybe even better than
an actual macbook
and the trackpad is also excellent
because it uses this unique design
that gives you even clicking all the way
around the trackpad compared to
this traditional compared to this
traditional
diving board design which makes it
really hard to click
at the top or maybe even in the center
with it being easy at the bottom so
in general you're paying more money but
you're getting the best keyboard case
ever
however you also get the option of the
logitech
folio touch which is 160
on the new ipad air and that one is
excellent as well and it comes with a
row of function keys
so it's really nice and now let's
finally finish with the conclusion
and i'd say that the ipad air 4
it isn't really worth upgrading from the
air 3 honestly
it does get the new design which is
really nice and it does support that
magic keyboard case
but the biggest downside is that you
don't have
120 hertz pro motion technology
because you're getting all of that power
but you can't really use it to the full
potential because you don't unlock
120 fps games and with the a12 chip on
the ipad air 3
it plays a lot of the games just as
smooth
as the ipad air so you're not really
taking advantage
of all that power unless you're doing
things like video editing or playing
extremely tough to play games maybe like
gentian impact or something like that
now the four gigs of ram compared to
three
is definitely nice but it's not that big
of a deal it's not that big of a change
i'd say that the six gigs on the pro is
definitely gonna be noticeable coming
from the air three
and by far the biggest downside with the
new air is that it still comes with
64 gigs of storage at the base price
just like the air 3 and that is a big
downside because it's honestly
not enough if you're going to be
downloading games or large
apps or doing productivity work using
the usb c port
and things like that and going up to the
next level
you get 256 gigs and you're already
paying 750 bucks
for that ipad air 4 and you're already
getting into
ipad pro territory the 11 inch ipad pro
is on sale right now for 750 dollars
and that is by far so much better
than the air 4. so to answer that
question
if you already have the air 3 or if you
have the ipad mini 5
it's not really worth upgrading to the
air 4. but
if this is your first ipad and you don't
want to spend crazy amounts of money
around 800 750 bucks this is actually a
great
first time ipad because this design is
going to be sticking around for
years and it matches up to the design of
the iphone 12
and that's very important if you want to
feel like you have a nice and modern
ipad
but with all that said i would highly
recommend that you guys watch our ipad
air 4 versus ipad pro comparison video
because there are just so many
differences
and the pro is just so much better in so
many different ways like the speakers
the microphones the displays definitely
watch that video
right over there and if you guys enjoyed
this comparison click that circle above
to subscribe
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]